So, there's this fantastic Wikipedia list
descriptively titled Wikipedia:Unusual Articles.
I just remember it as "That Wikipedia List."
It's a collection of hundreds of articles
about unusual, unexpected, and unbelievable
subjects.
No matter what link you click, it's bound
to be interesting.
For that reason, every week I'm going to click
on a new link and teach you a little bit more
about our amazing world.
Which way should toilet paper hang?
Over or under?
It’s a point of international contention
that’s been touched on by All in the Family,
Archie, and the Simpsons and creates rifts
in hundreds of marriages every year.
To understand the argument, let’s look at
the pros for each orientation.
We’ll start with over.
Perhaps the greatest objective advantage of
this setup is that it reduces the chance that
your knuckles will run against the wall.
This is more than an unpleasant experience.
It could transfer dangerous germs, especially
if you’re in a public restroom.
Over also makes it easier to grasp the end
since the loose end is visually distinguished
and further away from the wall.
Hotels, Cruise Ships, Office Buildings, and
others can also fold the toilet paper to indicate
that the room has been cleaned in the over
orientation.
Now for the under orientation, this way arguably
has a tidier appearance since the loose end
of toilet paper is more hidden from view.
It also makes it more difficult for toddlers
or pets to unravel the roll if batting at
it.
RV owners also report that the roll hung under
is less likely to unravel on its own while
driving.
As a quick sidenote, I’ll bring you a real
letter exchange between a customer and the
chairman of Southwest Airlines, Herb Kelleher.
The customer wrote, “Last week in my journey
to SFO someone put the toilet paper in wrong.
Any damn fool knows the papers come out the
bottom of the roll and not over the top.
I couldn't figure out how to correct the error
…" Herb responded, “Dear Jim: What the
hell were you doing upside down in our lavatory?”
Back to the debate.
In general, the public prefers toilet paper
hanged over.
Most surveys find between 60-70% of individuals
say they put their toilet paper in the over
orientation.
What’s more interesting, however, is to
look at who prefers which orientation.
Older people tend to have a higher preference
to hang their toilet paper over, while middle
aged people are most likely to hang their
tp under.
What’s most interesting is to look at preferences
by socio-economic class.
Sixty percent of people who earn $50,000 or
more prefer the toilet paper over while seventy-three
percent of people who earn less than $20,000
annually prefer the toilet paper under.
When the researcher Barry Sinrod was asked
what this means, he responded, “I don’t
know, but it’s sure interesting.”
One other research project concluded that
liberals prefer over while conservatives prefer
under.
Let’s now go a little deeper.
Therapist Gilda Carle theorized that the way
someone hangs their toilet paper can tell
you something about their personality.
She says, “If you roll over, you like taking
charge, crave organization and are likely
to over-achieve.
If you roll under, you're laid-back, dependable
and seek relationships with strong foundations.”
On another note, the Butler of Princes Diana
Paul Burrell was asked which method is better
and said, "Of course it should be over.
If it were down, it would unravel all over
the floor.
Royals don't have that problem though, because
they have sheets of tissue which are fanned
out into an attractive display and sit in
a box.”
So that’s one way to solve the issue, or
we could just look at the patent.
Oh, well that settles it.
It was made to hang over.
Come back next week for more intellectual
discussions.
Also click subscribe.